[موسيقى]
مساء الخير حياته بين الاعتقال والخروج عن
وطنه والتوقف عن النشاط السياسي لفتره ثم
العوده مره اخرى ليكون عنصرا مهم في
التغيرات التي تشهدها
مسيرته مليئه بالاحداث والتحولات خصوصا في
التيار الاسلامي كونه داعيه معروف واحد
القاده التاريخيه لحركه النهضه
في المعارك البرلمانيه من اجل الوصول الى
اهداف ربما حققها او لم يحققها حتى الان
الرئيس السابق للبرلمان التونسي بالنيابه
عبد الفتاح مبروك في سؤال مباشر سيد عبد
الفتاح اهلا وسهلا بك معي في سؤال مباشر
على شاشه العربيه
اهلا وسهلا تحيه لكم وتحيه لمن يساعدكم
ولمن يرانا من خلالكم
سيد عبد الفتاح من مقابله اجراءتها يمكن
قلت فيها بانك اعتزلت او لن تعود الى
العمل السياسي مره اخرى هل نزلت على هذا
الموقف ام تفكر بالعوده
لا ابدا هذا قرار نهائي قضاءه وضعي وسني
والمرحله التي دخلناها الان لم تعد مرحلتي
ولا مرحله امثالي لذلك خيرت ان اكون
مواطنا عاديا اعيش مع ابناء وطني لكن لا
اتحمل قيادتهم لان غير مؤهل لذلك احسن مني
هل تختلف اليوم يعني طريقه نظرتك ل همم
تونس تغيرات والمشهد فيها همم يعني لما
كنت فاعل في الحراك السياسي والان بعد ذلك
وتحول الى مواطن كما تقول مواطن عادي
لا يعني المسار كانهم متكامل لانه ما نراه
اليوم من احداث
ويعبر عن
رغبتي هذا الشعب في ان يتموقع في ان يجد
لنفسه طريقا فان يخط لي نفسه مسارا في ان
يحقق لنفسه اهداف
وهذا المسار هو مسار ليس سهلا لانه ما صار
تغيير
تختلف عليه الاراء والافكار ولكن يبقى
طبيعيا ان يوجد بين افراد الوطن الواحد من
الخلاف ما لا يتجاوز حدود الارتباط بالوطن
ذاته وان يختلف داخل الوطن وان لا ينقلب
على الوطن وان لا ينسوا حقوق الوطن عليهم
ما معنى ذلك يعني
كيف تفسر بشكل مبسط
[موسيقى]
خلافنا ينبغي
ان خلافنا لا ينبغي ان يتجاوز
المسلمات الاساسيه من ارتباط بتاريخ
وارتباط بحضاره وارتباط بواقع وارتباط
بمصالح وان هذا الارتباط ينبغي ان يكون
منشاؤه وهدفه الوطن ذاته لا خدمه اغراض
خارجيه ربما او اغراض بعيده عن ما يعيشه
المواطن في احساسه وشعوره وتفكيره
يعني هل تعتقد انه اليوم الخلافات خرجت عن
المسلامات الاساسيه اللي وضعتها اللي هي
تاريخ الحضاره همم الوطن هل هناك يعني من
يخدم لاغراض خارجيه الاهداف خارجيه
على كل حال انا العلم الذي بذلك لكن الذي
اقوله وان علينا ان لا نتجاوز الى التكفير
او التخوين هذا اني امراني فيهما حكم على
انتماء الفرد
وفيهما اعتداء على مسلمات الوطن لا نكفر
بعضنا ولا نخون بعضنا وبعد ذلك كل
الخلافات يمكن ان تحل
التجربه الاخيره يعني المتعلقه
بالانتخابات البرلمانيه يعني شهيده تونس
ربما اقل مشاركه او اضعف مشاركه حتى
العالم كله يعني كان يتحدث على ان حتى على
مستوى العالم كانت المشاركه الشعبيه في
ادنى مستوياتها ماذا يعكس ذلك برايك
يبدو انه يعكس خيبه امل الحياه السياسيه
انا المواطنين كانوا يتوقعون ان يكون
السياسيون اكثر نضجا واقدر على الخروج من
الازمه
وتراكمه الازمات على الوطن
ازمه الكوفيد وازمه الحرب القائمه في
اوكرانيا اليوم والتي
ظهر عشر على الحياه اليوميه للمواطن وشعور
الناس بان السياسيين لم يقدموا لهم حلولا
فيبدوا ان عزوفهم عن التوجه الى صناديق
الاقتراع يرجع الى هذا الشعور الذاتي
كانهم يعتبرون انفسهم قد خانهم السياسيون
ولم يعودوا يشتغلون بمصالحهم ولا يحققون
اهدافهم الذاتيه
يعني انت كنت داخل هذه العمليه السياسيه
ااا
حياتك كلها يعني تتموضع في هذه الحاله في
السياسه ثم الخروج والعوده كنت فعلا بشكل
كبير يعني خلال فتره من الفترات بذات
اثناء يمكن مع حركه النهضه التونسيه انا
اريد ان اسال سؤال انت كمراقب كداخل ايضا
في هذه لماذا فشلت التجربه تجربه
الاسلاميه تجربه حركه النهضه في في تونس
تجربه الحكم
والله كله تجربه سياسيه تستوجب
تخطيطا والتفكيرا وتستوجب كوادر وتستوجب
قدرات وهذه لم يكن يملكها
التيارات التي صعدت بعد الثوره لانها
تكونت على عجل ولان شبابها لم يكونوا
قادرين على ان يستوعبوا الواقع ويدركم
الواقع ويفهم ما المطلوب منهم وان
الكثيرين قد فتحوا خصومات عقائديها
وخصومات ايديولوجيا ايوه بقى ان ينكبوا
على معالجه الواقعي والسعيدي تغييره علما
بان اداره الشان العام ليست قضيه سهله هي
قضيه تستوجب معرفه تستوجب قدرات تستوجب
تخطيطا وهذا لم يتوفر لحركه النهضه في
تونس كما لم يتوفر لكثير من الحركات
السياسيه الاخرى ولذلك في تصوري الفشل كان
فشل د للجميع بالتفاوت المسؤوليه فيه
يقيننا لو وضعناها كذلك في نفس الاطار مع
تجربه الاخوان المسلمين في مصر همم سيد
عبد الفتاح ايضا كان الفشل هو العنوان
الرئيسي لهذه التجربه تجربه الحكم هل
تتشابه يعني عوامل الفشل عند الاخوان
المسلمين مع عوامل الفشل ام ان هناك فرق
بينهما نتحدث بين التجربه المصريه
والتجربه التونسيه بعد الربيع العرب
انا احتجز من الجواب في هذه النقطه لاني
اخذت على نفسي الا اتدخل في اي شان هذا
شان سياسي يتعلق ببلد المحترمه ونقدره
ونقدر ماضيه حاضره وننتظر منه مستقبلا ان
يكون في مقدمه النهضه الاسلاميه واللحظات
العربيه وان يقوده في المنطقه ولذلك
احترزه عن الاجابه اولا احتراما لما حصل
في مصر وما يحصل ثانيا لان المعطيات
المتوفره لدي ليست كافيه تجعلني قادرا على
ان احكم واقيم لكن في في
المشهد المنظور انه هناك نقائص عديده حصلت
من الذين تولوا السلطه بعد الثوره
2011 ادت الى هذا الانسداد انسداد الافاق
سواء في وطني او في كثير من اوطان العرب
مطلوب تحركت الشعوب ولكنها لم تكن على هدى
في تحركها وهذا يحتاج منا الى تقييم جديد
لواقع التحرك الشعبي هل ان شعوبنا اليوم
قادره بما لديها من امكانيات على ان تختص
لنفسها طريق الخلاص من هذا التخلف الذين
نعيش جميعا والذين مشوا والذي تحدثنا عنه
منذ قرن التاسع عشر القرن 20 وابين ان
نبقى تابعين لغيرنا وتحدث كل المصلحين في
اوطاننا على ان مال العرب والمسلمين ينبغي
ان يتحول الى مركز مرموق في العالم لكننا
لم نحقق ذلك الى الان ينبغي ان نسال
انفسنا ما الذي نقصنا في هذا التاريخ
على ان ناخذ مكانه انا اريد ان افهم لانه
يعني لا نريد ان انت لا تريد ان تتحدث عن
الشان المصري يعني تحديدا اضعها في الحكم
الاسلامي حكم هذه الجماعات الاسلاميه
لماذا فشلت يعني اين يكمن الخطا في هذه
التجارب التي حكمت فتره من الفترات ثم
الان
اصبحت يمكن في في سجون لفظها الشعب وهذا
المشهد يعني وحاضر وواضح في اكثر من بلد
عربي
سيد الكريم كلمه الحكم كلمه سهله عن
اللسان
لكنها في الحقيقه هي هي مسار ينبغي ان
تتوفر شروط نجاحه
الحكم والقدره على فهم الواقع الذي نعيش
المؤثرات فيه من يحكمون من داخلنا من
يتحكم في اوضاعنا الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
من خارجنا نحن كخيرنا من الشعوب معرضون
الى تاثير والى تاثير قوي من الذين يصنعون
والذين يبدعون الذين يطعموننا والذين
يكسوننا والذين يقدمون لنا حاجيات زمننا
هم من خلال ذلك لهم سلطان لا اقول مباشر
ولكن هم سلطان علينا حتى على المستوى
الادبي هل نحن قدرنا على ان ناخذ لانفسنا
باسباب عزتنا ومجدنا وان نكتسب لانفسنا
ما اكتسبوهم في قرون نهضتهم الثلاث او
الاربع التي سبقت القرن العشرين نحن اليوم
نتحدث عن تغيير في اوطاننا
ثلثوا شعوبنا لا تحسن القراءه والكتابه
نحن معزولون عن العلوم الانسانيه الموجوده
في العالم نحن لا نقرا نحن لا نتعلم نحن
لم نفتح كلياتنا ولا بنفتح مجتمعاتنا نحن
لم ندرح حوارا بين نخبنا وشعوبنا كيف يمكن
ان نتحدث عن حكم ونحن عاجزون عن ان يغفر
الاقل القليل من ماذا ذكرت لا اجد شعبا
قادرا على ان يخطط لنفسه طريقا اذا لم يكن
متعلمه واذا لم يكن واعيا واذا لم يكن له
صله بواقعه الذي يعيش ونحن معزولون عن هذا
لان عق اتعيش ماضيا سحيقا كنا اعزه فيه
وكل ما سئلنا عن واقعنا
تحدثنا عن ماضينا
وكاننا نعتبر ان ماضي انا العزيز وقدراتنا
السابقه تكفينا لان نكون اليوم في صداره
العالم مع النواقع الدنيا يقول خلاف ذلك
اذن نحن نحتاج الى هذا الوعي اذا هذا
الادراك الى هذا التغيير العميق في نفوسنا
حتى نقبل على اسباب العزه اذا كان الاسلام
قال لنا قبل ان يشرع لنا الحلال والحرام
اقرا
فكيف يمكن ان نبدع ونحن لا نقرا ونحن لا
نتعلم وعلوم العصر بعيده عنا عقولنا لا
تستوعب علوم العصر علوم العصر النفسيه
والاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه
والاداريه والرياضيه التي ابدعها غيرنا
نحن لا نسهر فيها ولا نشارك بين ما يمكن
ان يدفع الى التقدم بها حيث يمكن ان نتحدث
عن حكم طيب سنناقش معك بعض التفاصيل تحت
ما ذكرت في الجزء الثاني فاصل قصير
المشاهدين ونعود بعده للمتابعه في سؤال
مباشر
اهلا بكم من جديد ضيفي في سؤال مباشر رئيس
السابق للبرلمان التونسي بالنيابه عبد
الفتاح سيد عبد الفتاح مرحبا بك لم نقرا
لم نتعلم ندير حوار بين شعوبنا عقولنا
تعيش ماضيا سحيقا
لم نصل الى شعوبنا هذه هي العناوين التي
ذكرتها يعني وصفات ربما لتجربه الفشل لكنك
انت كنت داخل الدائره الحاكمه داخل دائره
العمليه السياسيه في تونس في فتره من
الفتره
لماذا لم يعني تقوم بفعل كل ذلك يعني في
تلك الفتره حتى تخرج من هذه من هذه يعني
المعادله التي يعيشها اليوم ونشاهد
اضرارها ونتائجها في الساحه التونسيه
جميل جدا هذا سؤال
يعبر عن حسن ظنكم بي لكن الذي تعلمه هو
نعلمه جميعا ان هذه التغيرات العميقه التي
ينبغي ان تحصل في العقود والافكار
والمجتمعات لا يمكن ان يقوم بها فرد واحد
ومهما اوتيا من قدرات وانا لست هذا الفرد
انا فرد مع غيري املك ان اعبر عن هذا
التشوه لكن هذا التغيير لا يمكن ان يحصل
الا اذا هدات نفوسه افراد الشعبي جميعا
وفتح الحوار الوطني نحن نحتاج لحوار وطني
داخل وطننا داخل بلدنا لماذا
لم يكن هناك حوار وطني اثناء يعني حكم على
الاقل همم النهضه اثناء فتره وجودك في
البرلمان في في داخل دوائر السياسيه لماذا
لم يبدا بذلك
لم يبدا بذلك لان الناس كانوا مكملين قبل
الثوره
فلما ازيل
المانع اراد الجميع ان يتكلم ويتكلم في
وقت واحد لم نسمع بعضنا نحن تشوفنا
وشوقنا وعطشنا الى ان نعبر عن انفسنا
جعلنا لا نحترم بعضنا والذين يتكلمون في
وقت واحد لا يبلغون ولا يدركون نحن نحتاج
اليوم الى شكل من اشكال الهدوء
ليتحدث الجميع وليفيد الجميع وليسمع
الجميع
هو الذي يساعدنا على استيعاب الفكر
المخالف لا ينبغي ان نبقى نحن كقطره الماء
يشبه بعضنا بعضا لان الله لم يخلقنا لذلك
التنوع هو الذي يمكن ان يقودن الى التغيير
وينبغي ان نعود اذاننا على ان نستمع ما
نحبه وما نكرهه والا نقول الا ما يحب
غيرنا ولو كرهناه نحن
طيب منذ اكثر من عام شهيده تونس تحولات
كبرى يعني على الصعيد
السياسي انا اتفهم انك قلت بانك لا تريد
ان تتحدث كثيرا في الموضوع السياسي لكن هو
موضوع الساعه السيد عبد الفتاح وانت تجل
حياتك تقريبا كانت في اطار هذا العمل
واطار كل التحولات التي شهد المشهد
السياسي في تونس فاعذرني ان اطرح عليك بعض
الاسئله
يعني قرار حل البرلمان وضع دستور جديد
هناك من وسط ما يحدث من تغيرات بانها
بمثابه احتكار من الرئيس للسلطات الرئيس
التونسي برر هذه الاجراءات بانها حمايه
لتونس وللشعب التونسي من الغارقين في همم
الفساد اجراءات يعني لتطهير المؤسسات
الحكوميه من الاخوان المسلمين كما يقول
بعض او يقراها المراقبون فبالتالي انت كيف
تقرا المشهد اليوم وانت خارج هذه العمليه
السياسيه
كمواطن تونسي
والله انا منذ ان حدثت هذه الاحداث وانا
عايشتها وعاصرتها وكنت اشاهدها واتابعها
على ان اخرج من هذا الصمت فردا انا استمع
الى مواطني كيف يعلقون ارغب في ان تنتهي
هذه المرحله تنتهي بفاق وطني ما حصل قد
حصلت سواء كان ايجابيا او سلبيا
ليس من دوري ان الشجوبه او اشكر عليه ولكن
انتظر ان نصل نحن الى خاتمه هذا المسار
بشكل من اشكال التوافق الوطني والا كتب
علينا ان نبقى بعضنا يبني وبعضنا يهدم
والذي يهدم الذي بنى والذي بنى ادم وبذلك
لا يقاموا صرح ابدا
وحوف الاوطان تقام بالتراكم بان يبني بعض
على بناء بعض يغير ما امكن ان يغير لكن
نصل بعد ذلك الى قدره في ان ينظر بعضنا
الى وجه بعض
الان سيد عبد الفتاح
المواطن هل يشعر بان الامور تتجه
هناك دعوات استمعت اليها وبكل اهتمام لا
ادري محتواها ولا مالاتها لكن
يسعدني كمواطن يريد ان يعيش في وطن هادئ
يسعدني ان يقع الحديث عن ذلك وان همم
يجتمع عقلاء الوطني ومفكروهم ونخابهم همم
حول
مثال يحتذى من قبل شعوبهم لان الخلاف على
مستوى النخبه ينتقل الى حرابا على مستوى
الشعوب ونحن لا نرغب بانقع في ذلك
هل هناك من يحاول ضرب تونس من الداخل سيد
عبد الفتاح
انا لاتهم احدا في وطنيته ولكن اقول ان
الجاهل يفعل بنفسه ما يفعل العدو بعدوه
فاهل يمكن ان يؤدي بنا الى تخريب بيوتنا
ولذلك نحن نحتاج الى رشاد نحتاج الى وعيد
نحتاج الى ادراك
تعلم الى استلهام من غيرنا حتى لا يتصور
الواحد منا ان مفاتيح الدنيا والاخره بيده
هو وهو وحده
وهل هناك من يحاول يعني الضرب بتونس ولكن
من الخارج هذه المره
ام على اساسي تحقيق مصالح
ولذلك طبيعي ان كل قوه تريد ان تجير
لنفسها ما امكن من اتباع يخدمون مصالحها
هل يقدرون على ذلك او لا يقدرون يقدمه
الدول
التي توشك على انهيار الاقتصادي وربما
الافلاس سيد عبد الفتاح انت تتابع هذه
التقارير تونس في وضع حرج جدا يعني هذا
الخطيب لانه اجتمعت
هذا اجتمعت علينا اثار الكوبيد مع الحرب
الاوكرانيه مع الجفاف الذي يعيشه الوطن
منذ سبعه اشهر تقريبا وهذا ادى الى رحاله
المواد الاساسيه في البلد والى عدم توفر
السيول الماليه التي تمكننا من ان ننزل
على السوق العالميه لنقتني حاجياتنا وهذا
خطر كبير احذر ابناء وطني من ان يتناسبوه
ولا يشعروا به وكل ذلك
بين تونس في كل المشاهد على المستوى
السياسي على المستوى حتى الاجتماع على كل
المستويات بالتالي لا مخرج همم اليوم ربما
كما يرى البعض من هذه الحاله في تونس في
ظل هذه الحاله من سداد الافق السياسي اول
الذي يمكن ان يصلح بعض الامور الاقتصاديه
اذا ما نجحت
انا في تصوري ان التوجه ينبغي ان ينصب على
الواقع الاجتماعي والاقتصادي بشكل اساسي
لان الجانب السياسي يمكن ان ينتظر لا يمكن
ان نتخاصم سياسيا ونحن جوعه لا يمكن ان
نتخاصم سياسيا وجزء من ابناء وطننا لا
يجدون الحاجيات الاساسيه الشعب لا يهم
الخلاف سياسي الشعب الذي يهمه
ان يشجع على الانتاج على العمل على
التنميه ينبغي ان تتوفر لدينا الامكانيات
التي من خلالها نصنع الثروه من جديد صعب
هذا سبيل ولكن هو السبيل الذي يمكن ان
ينقذنا وان نترك جانبا تلك الخلافات
السياسيه التي تعصب بكياناتنا والتي
تلهينا عن الاهم وهو توفيره مناعه ان
شعبنا حتى لا يحتاج في طعامه ولباسه
ودوائه وفي تربيه ابناءه هل وصلت
همم النهايه الان في تونس
همم
اراد الشعب ان يبعدها اذا كان هناك قرار
لابعاد حركه من الحركات فلا غير في ذلك
انتم تعلمون بان الاحزاب في العالم الغربي
تتداولوا على الحكم يسقط الجمهوريون ويصعد
الديمقراطيون يبقون ثمانيه سنوات ينزلون
يسقط الثاني العمال والمحافظون هذا طبيعي
جدا
ولا اتصور ان الحركات الاسلاميه تريد ان
تبقى في الحكم ابدا الدهر لان الدوام ليس
من شيمه الحركات السياسيه حركه سياسيه
تعالج واقعا متغيرا ينبغي ان تنسحب عن
الحكم اذا لم تكن قادره على ان تقدم
لمجتمعها ما يصلحها يعني ذلك انها لا تصلح
ابدا وانما يعني ذلك ان عليها ان تتطور ان
تاخذ باسباب المعرفه ان تفهم الواقع من
جديد وان تحين خياراتها وان تقوم بالرقابه
الذاتيه على نفسها
لتبين اخطائها تتبينها واذا اخطات فلا
تتاخروا عن ان تقول انا اخطات لان
الاعتراف بالخطا فضيله بل اعتراف بالخطا
سبب
قوه يجب ان يحاسب اذا كان يتحكم في مصير
شعب اليس كذلك سيد عبد الفتاح
يقيلا يقينا الخطا وخطاان
خطا سهوا
وخطا
وخطا العمد يجب ان يحاسب صاحبه
صاحبه سياسيه
[موسيقى]
المرفوعه عليه قضايا الذي يحمله الكثير
يعني مسؤوليات ما يحدث في في تونس عن رموز
حركه النهضه في فتره في فتره حكم انت معهد
توجهنا
سيدي انا
عضو في هيئه الدفاع كمحامل
ومكتبي منخرط في بعض هذه القضايا للدفاع
عن افراد منهم الاستاذ راشد
والاحترام لمهنتنا كمحامين يفرض علينا الا
نعلق على المحاكمات حتى تنتهي
وذلك لا استطيع ان اخذ في واقعي احداث
يتصدى لها القضاه الشرفاء الكرام الذين
نحترمهم ونحن ننتظر مالتي ذلك ومعركتنا هي
معركه داخل قصور العداله داخل المحاكم
وليست خارجه
شكرا جزيلا لك الريس السابق للبرلمان
التونسي بالنيابه عبد الفتاح
المباشر دائما يمكنكم متابعتنا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب
ومشاهده هذه الحلقه